I think it went down like this I think
Dax Shepard was like you know what I was
on that Punk'd show and somehow I landed
Kristen Bell I'm in the zone I'm gonna
start directing movies like Ben Affleck
why not hit and run so hit and runs the
story of a guy played by Dax Shepard
he's in the witness protection program
he's with Kristen Bell I mean he's in
the suburbs he's got no real problems
now life is good for him but then
Kristen Bell has to get to LA for a new
job and well he can't go to LAX that's
where all the [ __ ] went down ain't no
like illegal stuff the people he
snitched out they're gonna find out
about it but you know what it's all out
of love so this chivalrous bastard
elects to drive his girlfriend to the
hot zone of LA where he's probably gonna
get killed
so Dax Shepard actually wrote this movie
and he co-directed it with director
David Palmer and there were things that
worked in this movie things that did not
work in his movie
first of all Dax Shepard and Kristen
Bell they work together they work well
why because they're actually together in
real life because he was like well you
know what if I'm gonna do this I might
as well make it feel real and have my
real-life girlfriend we're gonna say the
two were actually cute together you're
rootin for Dax Shepard I was rooting for
Dax Shepard you know what he should take
that as a victory I'm just saying and
people actually played their parts well
like Michael Rosenbaum was the crazy
ex-boyfriend of Kristen Bell and he
knows the Dax Shepards in the witness
protection program so he's not really
who he says he is he's afraid he's gonna
like slice her up and put her in a box
or something so he's just freaking out
the entire time you know you're gonna
kill her he's kind of a funny psychopath
ex-boyfriend but whenever you can get
the best Lex Luthor ever portrayed to
play a funny psychopath ex-boyfriend I
want to see that [ __ ] Rosen Tom's a good
actor he did a good job in this movie
and then the one you have is Tom Arnold
Tom Arnold it was good in the movie he
plays this dumb [ __ ] US Marshal you know
he has to look after Dex Shepard witness
protection and all that it was good to
see Tom Arnold working in this movie
kind of reminded you why you liked him
in True Lies and of course you got a
touch on it Bradley Cooper's the guy
coming after Dax Shepard after he finds
out he's coming to LA Bradley Cooper's
the guy Dax Shepard snitched out to go
into witness protection so yeah Bradley
Cooper's a little pissed Bradley Cooper
and dreadlocks it's like face man from
the a-team dried up went surfing smoked
a lot of pot and now he's here you got
to wonder though did Bradley Cooper even
know he was being filmed in this movie
but Bradley Cooper's awesome he's a
badass you know you see him in this
movie for the first scene you're like
he's a really confident dude confident
but crazy the characters in this movie
had cartoonish elements but I didn't
feel like they were all cartoons that
element worked for what this movie was
what I didn't like is I felt like there
were too many characters in this movie
Tom Arnold great in the movie could have
been used more they have this weird side
characters Michael Rosen Baum's brother
he's a cop I really don't know why he
was in the movie if he was not in the
movie at all the movie would've been no
different so let's say you have Tom
Arnold with this much screen time and
this other cop with this much screen
time you eliminate the kind of useless
cop and you have Tom Arnold who can have
twice the screen time I think that would
have been a smarter way to go about it
you just feel like Dax Shepard was
writing this script and his friends were
like alright I'll make another character
for you who is going to snatch up screen
time from the other characters but hey
you know whatever I honestly expected to
hate the [ __ ] out of this movie but I
watched it and I had fun with it was the
movie perfect no but I was going along
with it and I was like I'm enjoying this
now don't get me wrong it's no Gone Baby
Gone with the town or anything like that
but it is enjoyable and in the fact that
I had a good time with the movie I will
say hit and run is a good time no
alcohol required yes apparently chase
scenes with cars are more fun than bikes
of the new movies out this weekend hit
and run came out on Wednesday but I'm
still counting it for the weekend of the
ones that I've seen it's the best one I
saw of the movies this weekend what is
your favorite whatever it is comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]